nous sommes au musée de la banane ici se
tenait une habitation du nom de limbé au
xviiie siècle
elle comptait 250 hectares depuis 1996
quatre hectares servent à abriter le
musée et sa collection variée tard à ce
jour le site est ouvert du lundi au
dimanche de 9h à 13h la sculpture avant
la crise commence à se faire une santé
elle a été frappée dans son élan c'est
un événement qui survient en pleine
saison touristique
c'est à ce moment là où l'on jean vitaux
sont refermées la banane quoi pour
rester dans le thème où l'on se fait un
peu de cash un peu d'activité et ça nous
est tombé dessus comme comme une grosse
massue et c'est très compliqué de se
relever de sa très très très compliqué
et nous pensons que de toutes les façons
vers la fin de l'année nous aurons
pratiquement au minimum à -7% d'autres
activités aujourd'hui plusieurs
partenaires apportent nos secteurs
touristiques une plus-value afin de lui
permettre de se relancer économiquement
tel le cnt le cas des roms la filière
asine et à l'office du tourisme pour ne
citer que ceux là
mais aussi une agence bancaire qui
permettra par sa contribution financière
aux martiniquais de découvrir ou
redécouvrir toutes les activités
touristiques considère qu'on a une
responsabilité sociale sociétale
économique
on a voulu prendre l'initiative mélange
vraiment c'est cette coopération moderne
et d'ailleurs avec des acteurs qui font
déjà des choses
l'intérêt c'est que finalement en créant
cette plateforme on permet à tous les
professionnels d'être référencé qu'ils
soient clients ou pas du crédit agricole
et on permet sciemment de faire un lien
avec aujourd'hui plus tôt les
martiniquaises et martigues et demain
avec l'ensemble du marché métropolitain
pour que la destination de la marque
matinik soit plus plus plus j'ai
reconnue et référencée
cette plate forme visible sur l'ensemble
toute la france et pour les acteurs du
tourisme comme nous qui sont en grande
difficulté pour nous c'était important
donc toutes les initiatives de la sorte
pour nous était donc après les très
importantes
après la crise le musée espère
reconquérir 50% des entrées soit 15000
personnes grâce à la mise en place de
plusieurs ateliers visites guidées
visites des différentes variétés du
fruit 65 en totale découverte de
produits dérivés de là
annan collation déjeuner à côté de 2021
des tickets seront accessibles en ligne
sur le site ww pour un tourisme by ca.fr